president Trump prepares for the release
of a classified memo about the Russia
investigation he's accusing top law
enforcement officials of political bias
the president posted this Twitter
message this morning the top leadership
and investigators of the FBI and the
Justice Department have politicized the
sacred investigative process in favor of
Democrats and against Republicans he
sent that tweet without providing any
evidence the memo accuses the FBI and
DOJ of improper surveillance of a Trump
campaign official the FBI says it has
grave concerns about the memos accuracy
and Democrats claim that Republicans
wrote it too in their words undermine
the Russia probe Paula Reid is at FBI
headquarters in Washington with more on
this story Paula good morning good
morning that tweet is curious because
the president personally appointed many
of the top officials at the Justice
Department coding the Attorney General
the Deputy Attorney General and the FBI
director but this memo controversy has
put him in direct conflict with his FBI
director director ray believes that this
memo should not be released because it
unfairly criticizes the FBI using
cherry-picked
information now we've talked to some
sources about these reports that Ray
could potentially resign over the
release of that memo and we're told that
is not true that is not his style and
that he is committed to serving out his
10 year term but we're also told he
could issue his own rebuttal if this
memo is released now to talk to senior
justice officials and they say this
tweet this memo controversy this is all
indicative of the unprecedented pressure
facing the Justice Department these days
they also tell me that typically they're
willing to share information classified
information with Congress with the
expectation that they will use it in a
discreet nonpartisan manner but with
this memo of controversy it's clear that
they're using it in the most partisan
way most public way imaginable and there
are concerns that that is really going
to fracture that critical oversight
bipartisan relationship now in talking
to rank-and-file they say they are still
100% focused on their job they're not
paying attention to what's going on here
in Washington but there are some
concerns
that the general public may start to
lose trust in the FBI Gail thank you
very much Paula